olá a todos meu nome é joe crucho muito
potável sou mágico obrigado porque deus
obrigado não precisava ser tão carinhosa
e muito foi conferido também não leva
cruzou mágico e com qualquer um
profissional da área e eu ainda me sinto
preparado julho
hoje em dia estou surpreendido novamente
a função de ser o único na sala
no entanto eu costumo ser contratado
para fazer festas todos de festas nos
batizados casamentos divórcios difícil
mas não tem fim
o turismo pode jogar tão exposta à luz
dessa pessoa amiga e grinalda
alguém sabe que isso é que não percebe
que isso é burro
se é um saco é um saco qualquer e
estamos a construir a minha artificial é
o saco de festa dentro de saco da tudo é
que o que é necessário para fazer uma
boa festa grandes por exemplo um
adversário mas dentro da festa
festas a gol foi a belê provas de festa
mas é que eu tenho dentro de um saco da
festa
acho que vão gostar você não sai muito
cansado pois não há festa que mais tenha
lento mas a constância de obstar
desculpas à chegada mas eu trago dentro
do meu saco da festa a estudar dentro da
área o goleiro salva de palmas para os
valores não não vou brincar cordas pra
mim antiga numa altura em que o
acessório que existe hoje
este aumento acordado que duas semanas a
treinar para isso - agradeceu a simpatia
ok obrigado a sentar aqui é não
precisava entender o que eu sei é claro
não entenderam o que eu disse é normal
eu explico quando essas molezinhas nós
sempre por palavras soltas lá dentro
assim quando eu acho que tentou fazer
coisas que vai coisas mas o que eu fiz
pra festa como é óbvio porque é não
opinam
sim é verdade e para quem ainda não
percebeu um cabo
às vezes é preciso aumentar
é isso é isso que eu faço na minha vida
que são daqui é um momento especial em
que nada faça aquilo que ao mesmo tempo
60 em todas as coisas como suas crianças
através do cheiro de guardado
é por isso que eu adoro ver a magia mas
não é por isso que eu faço na china não
é por isso que eu faço hoje eu sou uma
espécie de placa de som para fora da
pista
agora eu tenho a honra eo privilégio de
poder viajar espalhar magia isso ele na
função
sim aonde quer que eu paro apresenta uma
espetada no final espero que as pessoas
doem algo do seu dinheiro da gente
ficava na volta eu sei o que vocês estão
a pensar mas isso é coisa que eu não
sinto confortável bandeira
algumas das coisas mais bonitas das
nossas vidas
o casamento é uma das coisas mais
bonitas das nossas vidas mas o momento
prematuro penso assim
se eu sair à rua em busca de emprego e
não encontro
só existe uma solução eu tenho que criar
emprego
eu não se exclusivamente ser contratado
para poder trabalhar
eu posso prometer o meu padrão ir à rua
e trabalhar se arrisca quem corre é
fácil mas agora vocês vão ficar
surpreendidos com a generosidade da
maioria das pessoas pode ser bom mas
isso não chega vou me ajuda não chega no
banco na farmácia história do brasil com
a china visando não é assim tão difícil
se é assim todo porque eu não desisti
vou sair porque não vai procurar um
emprego de sábado
não é complexo porque em pouco
responsável através de energia vai
contactar directamente com pessoas com o
francês que já vividos momentos mais
cômicos
calado no passado dia 21 e que vou
prevalece uma senhora que atuar na mãe
ruim da praça central
eu sou de santarém leiria e tecnologia
porque a chuva mas eu já tinha adquirido
que fazer um espetáculo faça chuva ou
faça sol do histórico não vai fazer 80
havia uma criança
cerca de 50 interessados
eu chamei o pastor do mar vai gostar da
coisa vai acontecer no egito mas
obviamente vocês já sabem no entanto foi
ontem a companhia mesmo mesmo mesmo
momento que eu disse lhe enviaram fonte
de volta para seu lugar agradecer o
público reagir a alguma coisa não estava
clara a tensão é quando a vantagem é que
ia ser eu
eu vi que era minha meta é só mais um
das centenas números únicos que já vinha
banco
é por isso que eu faço hoje há no
coração
não é fácil
eu não estava a fazer é deixar vos só
com esta queda é de uma correção após
dar um facto
vivemos momentos extraordinários
o mundo comunica mais e mais rápido que
qualquer altura na história da
humanidade
o tempo médio dos resultados de busca da
google é menos de um segundo em menos de
um segundo
no entanto o tempo médio para um ser
humano muito maior uma conclusão em
relação a sua opinião em relação ao
outro ser humano em média 35 aqui quer
dizer não é só usar feito no espiritual
não é complexo e científica 5 da próxima
vez que forem passar na rua
acho que esta para falar na primeira
pessoa próxima vez que for é passar na
rua viram basca um artista rua faça uma
pausa de um minuto setembro
quem estava talvez tenha o privilégio de
presenciar um momento único
como fãs é minha profissão é mágico
eu não vou embora sem mostrar que o que
eu faço
além do óbvio vou mostrá los aqui o que
eu uso para fechar o meu próprio
espetáculo magia e para isso vou
precisar da ajuda de uma pessoa eu vou
dizer vou precisar do voluntário
se ninguém se voluntariar antes que eu
explico o conceito obrigado a crescer
mas salva de palmas para o favor
obrigado a colocar no google por mães
mas muito obrigado por ter vindo a uma
pergunta prático e para deus todos ao
mesmo tempo
quem aquela tecnologia com cartas não
está a correr muito bem ao meu lado não
quer saber eu vou fazer magia jogar da
mesma liga que vou fazer isso até que
gostem brasil de cara 3 está
familiarizado com o leste por favor
confessa que é um baralho de cartas
igual a qualquer outro horário de cartas
compra numa loja de energia
a conferência pode agregar importantes
por favor não a exploração é mesmo
porque preciso desse calor ótimo
fantástico muito vai senhoras e senhores
um baralho de cartas todas diferentes
todas iguais todos diferentes todos
iguais
como eu não estou satisfeito com o grau
de pobreza mais uma vez vai ser muito
simples eu vou deixar aquele as cartas
uma por uma desta forma quanto quiser
diz alto para stop internet pode tirar
essa carta por favor mostra toda a gente
precisa também
sim eu sei que vocês não conseguem ver
imaginem o twizy a próxima gestão é não
faz mal é indiferente em diferentes não
querem saber mesmo
muito vai mais utilizar o favoristimo
marcador para escrever o teu nome
não faça nas costas não exatamente
enquanto isso eu vou fingir que vou
estar na rua
não levem a sério essa para que entendam
o que eu faço é que eu vou mostrar a
seguir é que o chão perto de um milagre
se não mesmo um milagre qual camisa que
eu alguma vez qualquer um de vocês tiver
mais próximo do milagre a minha caneta
por favor pense rosa atrás da carta
assinada toda a gente por favor
até vou precisar que cox isto esta troca
e outra em frente a uma das duas mãos a
carta por favor sim mais fácil enquanto
opõe a luva senhoras e senhores toda a
gente pode ver lá toda a gente para
fotografias não tem só tem mais três
minutos
tá na cara que tem uma marca à frente
mas não tem marca nenhuma tragédia é
interessante eu vou colocar esta carta
no centro do baralho e vou pra ela no
centro do brasil
o kaká eu admito se eu soubesse
exatamente onde está não é onde está e
sei que ela está dentro do horário se
soubesse exatamente onde esta carta
estava eu seria no mínimo um deus
entrosamente alguns de vocês já devem
ter reparado que não é o caso nem faz
mal mas fazer isto tudo outra vez
em sua carta consegue falar e falar a
sério ea sério novamente no centro
quando toda a gente pode ver entrar como
se eu nunca tivesse visto a carta for
lida em voz alta é a primeira vez qual é
a tua casa com a tua
assim é que as crianças podem sim em voz
alta
olha a minha cara
an o favor diz em voz alta qual foi a
carta cruz crianças à creche para
escolhe qualquer isso três duros como é
que ninguém sabe é obrigado a empresa a
novela faz parte da equipa turca
admirável ouvir rock vai precisar deles
não tiro a luva vai precisar disto
senhoras e senhores
luanda o uso mesmo que não sai já a
carta escrita por favor eo nice tem um
respiro à vossa salvação de pé só
foi a quarta vez que participo favor
revela toda a gente não precisa estar
pensando em treinar e mostrar a toda a
gente
não não se você mora o tema obrigado os
grande obrigado como é o do profissional
treinando vou deixar ficar uma pequena
curva é um protesto de x com um abraço
mágico para o utente x ser é rui cruz ea
4 10 em 2014
alguém para clamar isto convosco muito
obrigado pelo convite
o algumas minhas coisas por favor não se
querer ficar com elas
obrigado pode voltar pode julgar ninguém
é obrigado querida pode voltar a ter
lugar também foi preso estar convosco
espero voltar a vê-los muito em breve
obrigado até a próxima